foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the dragon video in this video
let's go ahead and look at what's going
to be happening in the new episode
releasing on Sunday now the first thing
I actually want to say is after watching
HBO's official new video it looks like
this is about to be one hell of an
episode after watching everything unfold
in the last one we know we're about to
be in for an amazing ride throughout the
remainder of the first season the fight
over the Iron Throne is about to
officially begin in fact HBO's new
official video begins with us seeing
someone else sitting on the Iron Throne
as we all know viserys has been very
sick throughout most of this season and
now that we're finally heading for the
end he must be bedridden at the start of
the new episode that's why we see the
video begin as Serato stands before the
Iron Throne letting everyone know he's
there to speak on all matters for the
king this scene alone gives the show a
whole new Vibe because it's a glimpse of
what will happen once viserys is gone
the Iron Throne as well as Westeros will
be in the hands of house Hightower so
long as rhaenyra is living on
Dragonstone in the neck next shot we see
renera is back in King's Landing during
this meeting in the Great Hall of the
red key once again we see the actors and
actresses have been aged up a few more
years if he looks standing right behind
rhaenyra is her out of son Jace and one
of Damon's daughters that's either Rayna
or Bela Targaryen now these should be
the actors who stay in the show from
here on L you can also see the new
actors for viserys and Allison's
children in the following shot on the
left we have the older version of aegon
and next to him is aemond and then their
sister Helena now get a good look at
everyone standing there because this is
who will be fighting renera for that
Iron Throne they will be holding down
the city until someone is able to do
something about it in this next scene we
hear Rainier say those vipers rule in my
father's name Damon knows they must go
to King's Landing raniera is worried
about exactly what I just mentioned so
long as viserys is still alive and
bedridden Serato has the Iron Throne as
hand of the king and we all know what he
wants to do after viserys is dead Serato
wants aegon to succeed viserys not
renera and he's ready to fight to make
sure that happens now you would think
renera would want to go to King's
Landing and stay there while her father
is sick she knows her father is dying
and she knows her analysis have been
having all these issues why not leave
Dragonstone and stay in King's Landing
until your father dies Runner should
want to be in the capital when that
happens so she can Ascend the Iron
Throne immediately before Serato and
Allison make any more arrangements to
keep it away from her we then find out
the sea snake has gone back to the
stepstones where he sustained a grave
injury now what makes this interesting
is the look on vemon valerion's face
when that's set in the trailer when we
hear the sea snake has suffered an
injury his brother vamon has shown with
this evil looking grin on his face this
makes me wonder if he will try to take
advantage of the situation as we all
know Lord Corliss valerion's heirs are
now dead well lady Elena valerion is
dead and Lenor valerion faked his death
in the last episode we heard Corliss
valerion tell lucarius that driftmark
would be his one day now that his theirs
are dead and everyone knows raniera's
sons are bastards maybe theyman will
want driftmark for himself since lower
Corliss valerion has suffered this
injury he might want to make sure drift
Mark goes to him before some bastard kid
we do hear him asking rhaenys who will
take the Driftwood Throne we just may
see more than one fight over the line of
succession in this next episode in
another scene in this video we see sir
Kristen Cole in the yard with viserys
and Ellison's son a Mont Targaryen now
that we finally have the older actor
stepping in for aemon I'm very excited
to see what happens with this character
from here on out he will be one of my
favorites to watch especially now that
he has vegar not only does he have the
biggest dragon but they're also showing
us he still wants to learn how to fight
with his own weapons as well I think
he's going to be a lot of fun to watch
we then hear an old and weathered
viserys say the crown cannot stand
strong so long as the house of the
Dragon remains divided once again it
does sound like viserys is trying to
smooth things over with his wife Alison
and his daughter ranero we might see Al
Allison and renera try to make things
work one last time now in one of these
other shots we do see rhaenyra and
Allison's sons having dinner it looks
like aegon and jacaries are sitting side
by side until Jay slams his hands down
onto the table unfortunately it doesn't
look like they will ever be friends
because this dinner is over once
everyone starts fighting again here we
see Jace hit aemond in the face while
Lou carries and aegon fight right behind
them now there's no way to know exactly
how this started but my guess is someone
said something about aemon's eye or
runner's sons being bastards either way
all hell will break loose again not only
do rhenera and LSN hate each other but
so do their sons then we see Daemon
grabbing another dragon egg this one
might be for him and raniera's son in
the last episode we saw Damon and ranera
have sex and get married now that we're
jumping ahead a few years again Damon
and ranera might have already had their
son who they also name aegon I'm
thinking that's why we see Damon
grabbing the egg though so he can sit it
next to the newborn baby be so him and
the dragon can form an immediate Bond
now we also see Damon reuniting with his
former lover lady massaria the White
Worm this is also very interesting
because the last we saw of lady masaria
was when she was working with Serato
Hightower if you remember it was lady
masaria who informed Serato of Damon and
renera's nighttime activities in the
streets of King's Landing now we see
Damon meeting lady masaria in the
shadowy hallways of the capital I do
wonder is he buying or selling
information or is he looking for someone
to take a ride on his Dragon either way
whenever we see Damon wearing this Hood
we know he's up to no good the video
ends with us seeing vemon valerion
arriving in King's Landing as we hear
Serato say the threat of War lose
[Music]
it's definitely letting us know vamon
valerion will want something for himself
he will not be sitting on the sidelines
while everyone else fights over the line
of succession this man is about his
business so we will see him enter The
Fray as well so it does seem viserys
will be sick and bedridden leading to
Serato and basically his whole family
looking over the Iron Throne as you can
imagine renera will get worried so she
will arrive in King's Landing not only
to see her father but maybe also in
hopes of restoring her relationship with
Allison this will not last long because
their sons will fight again showing us
things will never work out with their
respective sides then Damon will shake
things up after meeting masaria and
vemon will look to shake things up while
localis valerion is out of the fight
this should make for an interesting
episode as everyone makes their last
minute arrangements before viserys dies
and leaves the Iron Throne vacant get
ready my friends house of the dragon is
about to set the stage on fire let me
know what all of you think down below do
you agree with what I said about this
video or do you think there is something
I'm missing leave me some of your
thoughts I always want to hear what you
have to say as always I want to thank
all of you for watching my video I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]